[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quanto pensato di a kandahar
non so perché l'immagine cadute quella
credete le mini strade è un camper in
realtà ax poi spesso si dice
chissà quando arriveremo seria di 7
miliardi oggi vedete che siamo quasi
diciamo quindi rottami sono talmente
altre riferimenti a tanta il passare del
tempo le giornate i compleanni le feste
comandate
ovviamente molto in realtà del canada
mera classica bomba dell'arsia minori
comunque riflettendo tutto mi ha portato
alla domanda che poi è quella a cui
cedere ma milano una risposta quando il
tempo dell'uomo e il tempo da natura si
sono separati casualmente rendermi pone
questa domanda
nella mia piccola cittadina abito al
fringe riunio succede un fatto che
succede
non tutti gli anni che quello
dell'invasione delle fine il problema
che quest'anno questo fatto e finito sui
giornali nazionali sulle radio nazionali
si inizia da scooter nel film che sono
delle farfalle e sono anche cosa più
importante gli indicherà tecnologici io
prima non sapevo popola il mio amico
roberto cavallo ha iniziato una
discussione sui social perché la gente
si lamentava questo giorno e mezzo di
vita di queste farfalle interrompe
vita di tutti i giorni perché diciamo
sul ponte che attraversa il fiume tardi
acqua
bisogna piano perché c'erano tutti le
farfalle monte e quindi non si toccano e
è questo che abbiamo proprio a fagiolo
la spinta quanto su quanto stavo
riflettendo io perché la gente e gli
esperti anche star di vita al lancio
come evitare questa pasqua tant'è che è
mio amico roberto cavalli spiegano ma
scusate vuol dire che l'acqua della sua
figlia per l'it non è messa contenti non
mi prendo una meta che però nessuno
seguito ragione infatti ad un certo
punto livello d'istruzione arrivato su
cremona utilizzata per evitare che
investire moltissimo che sarebbero dura
la partenza che scappa infatti un certo
punto nelle discussioni sui social è con
questo costruzione cittadina si è
racchiusa tra leggendo va bene
probabilmente presidente del vostro film
e si è sporto quindi esattamente quando
è un persol armonia con quello che ci
circonda con la natura con madre terra
in un'idea me la sono fatta né
immaginare qualcuno di voi possa avere
in mente il perché il quando però è bene
sempre studiare argomentarsi quindi alle
mie spalle di un grafico nel caso
specifico ci racconta l'andamento della
c2 nel tempo e quindi vedete che in 150
anni non abbiamo avuto un piccolo
significativo prima nulla
quindi diciamo c'era questa sorta di
armonia dopo
come tale possiede in grillo la
produzione industriale quindi è facile
però è anche vero che gli altri grafici
e tutti avevano questo andamento quello
già citato la popolazione mondiale
altri dati la una quantità di halloween
ata e altre tematiche di questo tipo
e allora ho pensato può andare
all'infinito
è la risposta era facile no
viviamo in un sistema finito il nostro
piovuta che il soggetto come tutti i
sistemi infiniti è stato un ateo
quindi se ne sa turrina monso pianeta a
problema il cercava un countdown ho
trovato lovascio dei io non so se tutti
sanno che si tratta però è il momento in
cui noi umani
terminiamo le risorse del pianeta che
tenta pure generale in un anno quindi
nel 2016 è stata l'otto agosto nel 2017
statuto agosto nel 2018 è stata prima
vostro quindi iniziato a preoccuparli
c'è un countdown ed è importante però ho
pensato che si potesse fare qualcosa
però anche dei promo e che pensate come
saranno il nostro futuro di lavoro mi
occupo di rifiuti che avrete capito
della presentazione spesso e volentieri
come facevano i detective degli anni ne
fine degli anni 90 mi trovo aprire
sacchetti dell'immondizia anziana tra
non differenziata di più dei punti di
vista
un po come facendo il the tecnico nel
cielo prima anche se avesse ormai è
tutto però in realtà dei sacchetti della
spazzatura si comprende molto di come
siamo noi e spesso non è piacevole
scoprire come sia alle mie spalle vedete
due immagini del monte di cocci roma una
discarica antica
dall'altra parte invece c'erano una
discarica moderno e ho pensato ma chissà
cosa penseranno i nostri giorni
ma oggi quando troiano monte dei cocci o
cose simili
lo chiamiamo un sito archeologico in
gioco quando scaveranno in diversi costi
e troveranno quello che invece vediamo
dall'altra parte cosa pensando ad
asciugare e questo devo dire che mi ha
inquietato non poco spesso e volentieri
noi approcciamo tutti i problemi un po
il contrario
un po in emergenza
io non so quanti di voi conoscono
definita gerarchia dei rifiuti
insomma c'è un modus operandi però per
approcciarsi ai rifiuti è detta anche la
cinquina regola delle 5 la riduzione e
riuso la raccolta differenziata il
recupero di materia e poi il recupero di
energia perché una volta poi è anche lo
smart tv finali quindi recitata in
discariche ecco noi abbiamo sempre
apprezzato questo problema al contrario
cioè ci siamo prima preoccupati di
nascondere i nostri rifiuti lungo più
sto a dirvi nella mia città ci hanno
costruito sopra un tribunale sotto la
discarica antica di alba e quindi
dobbiamo procedere la parte sbagliata
noi abbiamo pensato che come fa nemmeno
come facevano i nostri nonni a
riutilizzare alcune cose invece che a
sabotare riina e poi quello per cui una
casa mostra otterranno farà la quota
differenziate così la cosa incredibile
che si riflette ci riesce tornati ma che
le prime 3 ad una riduzione il riuso e
raccolta differenziata
sono una sponsabilità sono le nostre
mamme ce la facciamo noi non dipende da
nessuno per una nostra scelta
ed è una scelta che possiamo fare tutti
i giorni
io che meno tutte le domeniche nella mia
organizzazione mediana vado a fare la
spesa avuto forma del consiglio
supermercato lo dico da subito non è una
cosa che viene naturale però con la biro
faceva box sono avvantaggiate tra queste
attività quindi quando scorre in queste
corsie
quindi c'è ma attivo la mia attenzione e
quindi inizia a guardarla come sono
fatti imballati c prodotto qatar hanno
in mano
quanta carta quanta plastica intorno se
c'è la confezione che può produrre meno
rifiuti così via
proprio perché dobbiamo partire dalla
riduzione tra l'altro c'è un'occasione
alla mano tra poco inizia la settimana
europea delle reazioni dei rifiuti
quindi a livello europeo ci sono
tantissime iniziative che ci insegnano a
con a ridurre i nostri rifiuti
anche perché previene un computer una
frase che
cioè di solito si dice siamo quello che
mangiamo e l'ho io una deformazione
professionale iniziato a pensare sia
comune rifiuti che produciamo il mondo
delle plastiche il mondo delle plastiche
e un mondo sconfinato ne esistono più di
100 tipi polimeri poli agropirati
immagino che voi tutti i giorni che in
via perché fare
faccio qualche esperimento dove vado a
fare la spesa poi torna a casa e se
fanno subito tutto per capire che vuole
una che in quantità che tipo di plastica
o intanto è complicata ci rendono una
vita complicata differenziarne
utilizzarle plastiche per parlarvi di un
tema forse non più importante però
fondamentale che la comunicazione
da qui con due riferimento in
particolare se uno fa un collega su
internet si accorgerà che le industrie
che investono più soldi della pubblicità
sono principalmente due persone sotto
categorie ma prima ed automotive ci
spingono a comprare le macchine più
belle altri performanti la seconda entro
2 quantità di acqua in bottiglia
c'è qui questi signori in me investito
parecchi soldi
teniamo conto che noi siamo anche nel
parcheggio delle arti degli appennini
delle colline quindi a casa dovrebbe
arrivarci dell'acqua buona in partenza
sicuramente per i comuni dovrebbero far
bottino non intenzione vero però oggi
quelle casette l'acqua e con altre con
altre strumentazioni possiamo
sicuramente troiane però un'altra cosa
con inutilmente che forse pochi sanno è
che la seconda voce di piangere comune è
proprio quella solo in cina ma comprende
anche la propria infanzia
stamane però di contro l'assessorato
all'ambiente non è che senza portafoglio
però li na vengono proprio pochi quando
gli assessori precedenti hanno fatto il
loro e questo è un problema io lo spiego
spesso durante la mia attività può
esserci un bellissimo progetto tecnico
ma se non accompagnato da una campagna
di comunicazione che sono che quella
titta che sembra creare la cultura
perché la raccolta differenziata non
aspetto culturale non è solo avere il
cassonetto o il video né col sacco da
casa quindi se non investiamo in quello
non riusciremo mai a cambiare l'aspetto
culturale e vi assicuro che chi lo fa
tutti apre dovuto chi comprende questo
tema è possibile cambiamento culturale
anche in zone latitudine dove
solitamente diciamolo si dice che non
fanno la raccolta differenziata come
dicevo che qualcosa avesse possibile
ogni tanto mi sembra che ci siano delle
cose che siano proprio possibili ed esse
in particolare mi riferisco al ii e
l'ing parola inglese
spesso si usano mangiatorella inglese il
littering e quel fenomeno di abbandono
volontario
la sua di disciplina abilità dico che mi
siano impossibile perché veramente ormai
vedere appoggi al comune dal finestrino
figli dal i propri rifiuti o guarda in
un parco lascia qualcosa per terra e
lontana dalla mia logica
spero anche dalla boxe e la mente
insieme a littering vi sono tre due
riflessioni
la prima che gli italiani siano un po
stupidi
lo dico perché recentemente sono
professioni servizi sul fenomeno svedese
il blogging che gli svedesi ma non fuori
a correre mentre corno la colla nei
lucchetti chinano la schiena
ho pensato ma cribbio in italia c'è
un'iniziativa che si chiama punisce le
coppie che è vecchia di cinque anni dove
facciamo la stessa cosa
poi ci lamentiamo nella fuga di cervelli
però anche noi andiamo a cercare le
notizie
rispetto invece l'immagine che dietro è
l'associazione colletta di cenni data
importante che mi vuole lasciare vediamo
nelle immagini ma la nominati però devo
ricordarvi che 70 per cento dei riusciti
che finisce in mare arriva dall
entroterra
cioè noi abbandoniamo nel nostro parco
queste montagne de vicienti questi
entrano nel sistema ma non è l'unica
scordata nel male ero inquinano non è
una pura via io spesso e volentieri va
dai montane per i figli in the coming
are here home ha spiegato loro cose
particolari non è che mi sono messo in
fondo una lezione frontale per loro papà
fa il lavoro del riciclo veramente non
vuol dire niente mia figlia ha detto ma
quando io farlo lavoro del riciclo
totale faticosa voi non lo sappiamo
siamo in montagna lavoro si appendono
sacchettini detronizzando si metteranno
incolonnati dietro e quando avendo di
rifiuti
riprendono di mutualmente un'immagine
bellissima nel senso pensando il futuro
è qualcosa che in qualche modo e mi
rincuora io faccio questo tutti i giorni
in cui i miei colleghi
cerco di carico della cultura per
evitare che il sistema si sa che qualche
tempo fa ci hanno chiamato perché
c'era un'idea un'idea forte la più
grande manifestazione in italia anche la
più conosciuta retina aspettarci quella
che si spande negli sul territorio
voleva fare qualcosa nel campo
ambientale non abbiamo un'idea precisa
tant'è che loro noi siamo alle tv gli
abbia proposto di fare la raccolta
differenziata dell'italia e sono so se
tutti voi avete chiave in testa che
numeri francia e italia però parliamo di
ventuno tappe sono 42 comuni coinvolti
intendo le partenze degli atv parlo di
14 milioni di persone e mezzo tre
partenze arrivo le altre sul percorso
che assistono a questa manifestazione
il gen italia a dire la corsa più dura
nel mondo nel paese più belle del mondo
quindi teniamo lo bello questo paese era
fondamentale e quindi ci siamo messi lì
abbiamo fatto la raccolta differenziata
la cosa più incredibile anche noi è
sempre signor g vitaletti
andiamo anche nei posti della raccolta
differenziata annuncia quindi si punta
molto insieme quando la gente viene
veniva passione isole si faceva raccolta
differenziata e c'era il volontario che
indicavo la debuttante il rifiuto la
cosa più bella che accadeva anche in
quei posti dalla fama raccolta
differenziata era la parola grazie
la fortissima spesso lasciano ai
volontari interdetti quindi la forza del
messaggio del giro italiana legata al
fatto che spesso e volentieri
chiediamo a casa direttamente i rifiuti
e poi poi mandiamo nelle manifestazioni
questa non abbina e quindi un messaggio
mi muovo la con navigazione a metà
faccio la festa in piazza non faccia
differenziata procacciatore di faceva
molto sana farà quel potere le sagge
riggi l'italia che portiamo la mano in
giro da 34 anni
non mi sbaglio avrete un bacio non è un
bacio normale questo vaso diciamo è
stato riaggiustato utilizzando una
filosofia
non so se noi la conoscete si chiama con
suu kyi
poi c'è la plancia chiederò il kit luci
ci dice che rottura la riparazione sono
parte di un processo di cambiamento
quindi in questa notte non come faceva
di lavandino le fatture vengono
banalizzate questa cosa qui con loro ma
sia per le cose che per le persone
ecco io auguro a tutti noi di poter
ricordare la rinsaldare per farlo
rendere i punti più deboli più forti e
poi se conoscete 7 delle l'acqua in
bottiglia prima di mettere la raccolta
differenziata è importante che la
schiacciata grazie
[Applauso]